[FILM ROLLING]
[MUSIC PLAYING WITH ROBOTIC
VOICES]
The world is very different now.
The world is very--
[STATIC AND ROBOTIC VOICES]
[MUSIC PLAYING OVER RADIO]
[STATIC]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SEAGULLS SQUAWKING]
As beautiful as it once was.
[CRASHING]
[SEAGULLS SQUAWKING]
As beautiful as it once was.
[ROBOTIC VOICES]
[ETHEREAL SINGING]
[DEEP DEVILISH VOICE]
[AIRPLANE TAKING OFF]
(SINGING) On the
red road, it's 1976.
The bases are loaded.
On the red road, a blood maiden
is ruined from the start.
It's tough to win two in
a row on the yellow road.
It's 1976 give that
[? ball ?] a [? chance. ?]
[? I'm ?] [? mercy. ?]
I'm a magician.
I'm the new man here,
guided by invisible hands
to an unknown land.
On the white road, it's
1976, mirror symmetry.
On the white road, it's 1976, so
hell is thick with [? tests ?]
and [? heaps ?] and
piles of [INAUDIBLE]..
A darkened house a white
tiger, a spherical life.
A darkened house, a white
tiger's spherical life.
On the black road, it's
1976, [? wing ?] [? and ?]
[INAUDIBLE].
On the black road, it's 1976,
sudden death on the road.
Blood on the mirror, [? five ?]
[? of ?] [? five, ?] sudden
death on the road.
Blood on the mirror, [? five ?]
[? of ?] [? five. ?] I've got
to slow this down
and close the blinds.
I've got to slow this
down and close the blinds.
I'd love to slow this
I've got to slow this
down and close the blinds.
[AIRPLANE TAKING OFF]
[CAR PASSING]